either L time or Carson have on the ice for all 11
goals scored by the PS so far this season here's
a gety maret off to a hot start dropping it back
on brownley Smith in front score Mulan 53 seconds
in to make a change and then they moved the Pu
from one side of the ice to another who that's
way too much him for Malin to enter the zone
and push back to D and what a pass there by
Riley Smith you give time and space to Malin
like that he's going to find another play I
actually thought he was going to cut to the
middle and rip this Puck instead he draws a
Defender hands it off to Riley Smith and you talk
about a beautiful back here's gzel for the pins
back out pson across crossby on the doorstep and
huto got a piece of it the Tang back on it for
the Penguins Graves tried to move it up the boards
here's Christian fer with a stuff attempt stop by
[Applause]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] jar
just over two to play in the first Here Comes
Carter moving in on whoo who makes the start
[Applause] tried the return off the skate of
Raymond and sent back into the Red Wing Zone
0:01:59.840,1193:02:47.295
[Applause]
Petri up the middle Here Comes Larin cutting
wide on Joseph Lin touch to the slot back out
for jck scar two1 Red [Music] Wings cuts to the
middle of the ice and then sherat little bit of
tangle in front of the net with Tristan jar here
know if he was able to get set as Raymond went
to the net and rued Ru Weedle was there but
Advantage Red Wings and they take advantage
well and it's at speed of Lin right I mean
he has the ability to turn on the J you have
to respect it when he hits the breaks there's
time and space and then he finds a late cherat
now Malin hains for the far circle and a
save on Rael BYO first Pittsburgh shot of
the period here's Harkins Crosby cutting for the
net Harkins out in front of the save by h on Ryan
p f look for the puck Joseph there as well out to
the right side for Petri score CP
Crossing in front 31 Red [Music]
Wings opposite side it goes on his backand
so he's got to go backhand forehand and he
gets a lot on this and then the redirect
by Andrew cop excellent play all the way
around by the Red Wings low to highs get
the puck down now that look looked like
the puck was or the uh the contact was
made above the height of the crossbar
that one lower level look SP back out to
moider Kan C spare cider straight away
watch by Neo there's Lin shoots score on the
rebound foron power play goal 41 Red Wings
great Puck movement here by the Red Wings
they' been quicker in this period quicker
to pucks quicker to move pucks and a real
good job of just zipping this Puck around
this Puck never actually gets the jar
off the one timer but David pan is in
the right spot it does I mean he got
redirected on the way in and pan good
net front presence and able to catch it
in the back of the neck both penalty boxes
full teamcap for aside that hor reminds me
a Chuck manone down there will be down the
4D Falon still in the hit Penalty Box as well
score Carlson cuts the Red Wings lead for
4-2 they hop the boards Pittsburgh able to
gather the puck in a good feed by Crosby who
caught Carlson coming off the bench he's in
a soft area Catch and Release and a perfectly
placed shot to the far side of the net there's
Riley Smith Puck knock away race for the puck
C and the tag cop has it moving in he deeps out
of stop by Jory it'll be a penalty shot perhaps
a penalty shot it will be oh big save there by
Tristan jar but watch this Chris L Tang Dives
and then reaches in up cop great a penalty shot
for Andrew cop he was stopped by Spencer Martin
of Columbus moving in on jari cop shoots of
stopped much a shoot out from there I mean
he's trying to go low block Tom has been their
play through the middle of the ice I they have
really Managed IT well and once they get it I
mean and there they've got some speed I mean up
and down the lineup pson for Carlson score maybe
Russ Kenny maybe Russ yeah I think it was tip dead
though who if I'm Derek lone I I call a timeout
here I think you got to Corral this thing in
here yeah no chance foro there that puck
is going right for the the corner of the
two posts just what a job I I believe Ross got
it I think oh yeah he did he did no doubt about
it but he just did a great job of battling to
get there and then just get a stick on it was
not going to be denied P Crossing with pson now
Crosby Rush jum blocked Carson over to pick it
up bin couldn't handle the pass Red Wings gain
position it's CAU and that is empty B shoots he
scores [Music] well this Puck takes a bad
bounce over the Stick of of gny
Malin and then cop who gets the
[Music] step says I'm not going to
be unselfish here I got a wide open
net and I'm going to put it into the
back of it is using coach's challenge to determine
if it was offside prior to the scoring
of the goal oh my goodness could you
[Music]
imagine go back we go back just a little
just to let people know that pck has to
be completely over the blue line after
video review the callon The Ice stands
we have a goal so now it's five on
five with Harkin serving the delay of
game penalty four the eight goals tonight
scored by Michigan natives that is empty
score it is down 63 the break it makes
it five out of nine for the Michigan
board players in this game the T wins it six to
[Music] three